on Monday the New York Board of Regents
announced it would dump the academic
literacy skills test they didn't dump
the test which was designed to test
teachers on reading ability in order to
raise standards because there's anything
wrong with the test per se they dumped
it because too many minority teachers
were failing it one of the members of
the task force that looked at the
teachers certification test professor
Leslie Sudak of Pace University said
quote having the white workforce really
doesn't match her student body anymore
it turns out that according to ABC News
54% of Hispanics and 59% of blacks who
took the test failed it on the first try
as opposed to 36 percent of whites does
that mean the test was racist nope a
federal judge in New York not exactly a
bastion of conservatism rule the test
was fine that wasn't enough though for
the state of New York where it's more
important that your teacher is black
then that your teacher can read and
understand material suit X comments were
echoed by National Council on teacher
quality president Kate Walsh who seemed
merrily dismissed test results quote
there's not a test in the country that
doesn't have a disproportionate
performance on the part of blacks and
Latinos but she acknowledged that
getting rid of the test would be a step
in the wrong direction here is the
problem the students there's this weird
notion on the left that students learn
better from teachers of equal quality so
long as the teacher shares a race with
those students a good deal of research
finds weak or no evidence to
substantiate that claim and that's
assuming the teachers are of equal
quality there is no evidence none Zippo
zilch that an inferior teacher of the
same race is better for a student than a
superior teacher of a different race yet
it's that latter hypothesis New York
wants to now pursue so New York State
now wants to sublimate the interests of
its students to the interest in
political correctness better for a black
kid have a black teacher who failed the
alst then they have a white teacher who
passed it statistically of course this
means a higher likelihood the black kid
will have an under qualified teacher
than a white kid since we're now
attempting to race sort rather than to
hire meritorious teachers that creates
new intergenerational pathologies a
failed education for which presumably
the left will blame white racism and
test discrimination without evidence
meanwhile the kids continued to fail
well done New York I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so we have lots to talk about
including the greatest media fail of my
lifetime I mean this is a giant epic
sized media fail and it is glorious in
every way it is possible for this to be
glorious and we'll talk about Rachel
Maddow and her giant fail of epic
proportions in just a second but first
we have to say thank you to new sponsors
over at blinds.com so I'm very excited
to be working with blinds.com
I've heard about them for years they do
fantastic work in your home so the way
that this works is you got old blinds
you got those crappy old kind of plastic
blinds that your grandmother put up
years ago
and you want to get rid of those in a
place those are something nice it
doesn't look like something out of the
set of the wire and so you go out and
you go to blinds.com and instead of
going to like Bed Bath & Beyond or any
of these other stores and trying to
purchase really really expensive blinds
and you have to put them up yourself and
they're not properly tailored to the
specifications of your windows
blinds.com makes it super easy for you
if you're not sure what you want or even
where to start you get a free online
design consultation then you can go on
their website and you can specify you
measure your window and then you specify
what the window size is and what kind of
blinds you want and they cut it to
specifications they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
and your furniture and specific rooms so
if you're a dude and you have no idea
what exactly the blinds should look like
in your house they have somebody who
definitely will and then they send you
free samples to make sure that
everything looks the same as it does
online in person and if you miss measure
or I should pick the wrong color if you
screw up the lines come we'll make your
blinds for free
they'll remake them for free okay so if
you make the mistake they'll make them
for free which is awesome that's an
amazing deal they've made it really easy
for you
blinds.com for a limited time you get
20% off everything at blinds comm when
you use the promo code been 20% off
everything in blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben blinds.com promo code Ben
they've got faux wood blinds and
cellular shades and roller shades and
more I've looked at their product it
really is spectacular high quality stuff
it's gonna really upgrade the look and
feel of your house it can even help with
energy costs because the blinds they
sell are gonna be better than probably
what you got on there right now in terms
of keeping out heat blinds calm promo
code Ben blinds.com promo code Ben there
are some rules and restrictions but it's
blinds.com promo code Ben
sure that you used that promo code Benz
to get the 20% off your entire order
which is an awesome deal plus you let
them know that were the ones who sent
you
okay so rachel maddow has herself in
evening last night and it is just hi
Larry oh so here's how it went about 335
yesterday afternoon Pacific time Rachel
Maddow goes to Twitter and she says we
have Trump tax returns we have from tax
returns and everybody goes crazy that's
crazy
oh my goodness we're gonna finally find
out what he's been hiding for all these
years what is he hiding from what
doesn't he want people to know is he
secretly named Dmitri Trumpkin what is
his is he in the pay of the Russians
does he have no money as he actually
broke has he been stealing money from
small children we don't know now we're
gonna find out because Rachel Maddow has
all the new information there's this
massive buildup on Twitter huge buildup
and then she shows up on air and for
like 30 minutes she does this wrong lead
up this long drawn out and I don't watch
Maddow
but a lot so I can't speak to whether
she does this regularly apparently she's
kind of famous for this she doesn't like
ten minute monologues that don't lead
anywhere and then finally she gets to
the news and she did that last night
except it felt like hours and people on
Twitter were going nuts won't you just
get to the meat of the matter as my
father you say gets the meat of the
matter Uncle Eddie
like at some point you're gonna have to
actually tell us what's in these tax
returns and finally she gets there and
sad trombone here's Rachel Maddow last
night on MSNBC there are definitely
personality-driven
and petty reasons to seek the
president's tax returns is he not as
rich as he says he is
it's he not as charitable as he says he
is what's he in fact under audit when he
was using that as an excuse to not
release his tax returns was that worse
than just a bad excuse was he really
being out of it there's small reasons to
be interested right but whether it's for
small reasons or big reasons there has
been an unrelenting demand by people to
see his tax returns more than a million
people have signed to the White House
petition demanding that he releases tax
returns but with all of that the
concerns about whether he's gonna be
self-dealing in tax policies concerns
about whether he might have lied or
misrepresented as
financial circumstance during the
campaign concerns about whether or not
he might have missed the big national
security worry is there a way faster she
pulls the tax returns because you just
goes a great concern incessantly like
this Donald Trump still returns know to
expect up still going has decided to
leak okay here we go
a portion of his 2005 tax return which
is how and why we got it tonight and I
am sure it is only the start but it's a
start and our little piece of it we just
got it I'll go through it okay so then
she goes to break right get you
throughout the commercial break finally
what does she reveal what does she
reveal she reveals the Donald Trump in
2005 paid 150 he had made a hundred and
fifty million dollars in in income and
he paid 38 million dollars in taxes sad
trombone because you know what they were
hoping is that he never paid any taxes
right you know the weather what they
were hoping is that he's declared a loss
every year for for for all time that he
will he's not a billionaire it turns out
that 150 million dollars to make an ear
that's a lot of money
the average household income in the
United States is similar around fifty
six thousand dollars so if you were to
earn that average household income for
two thousand and six hundred years you
wouldn't hit 150 million dollars he made
that in one year so number one Trump is
super duper rich well done Rachel Maddow
you've broken the story you've got the
silver bullet Donald Trump is no longer
president it's unbelievable I love when
she says but it is a start as though
she's actually gonna break something and
then she breaks they just made a
crapload of money and paid a crapload of
money in taxes and that's the other part
already paid thirty thirty eight million
dollars in taxes thirty eight million
dollars okay that's a lot thirty eight
million dollars that crap in one year in
taxes not only that his effective tax
rate that year was twenty five percent
you know what Barack Obama's effective
tax rate was in 2015 it was nineteen
percent you know Bernie Sanders is
effective tax rate was in 2014 it was
thirteen percent you know Comcast which
owns NBC you know what their effective
average tax rate has been from 2008 to
2012 twenty four percent in other words
Donald Trump in this one year of tax
returns that they have paid more as
centage of his income than any of the
people that I just mentioned but they've
been saying for years that he paid no
not like zero taxes none so what did
they come up with I love this what did
they come up with to try and spin this
as though Trump did something wrong well
you know Trump only paid that much in
taxes because of the alternative minimum
tax the alternative minimum tax is this
idiotic tax provision that basically
catches you if you have a lot of
deductions and you make a lot of money
then it basically jacks your rate back
up
and Trump wants to get rid of that
because he says that's not fair you know
you're basically it's just a money grab
and say well if Trump had his way he
would have paid not very much in taxes
at all right and if I had my way I'd pay
nothing in taxes legally because the
fact is that I don't want to pay all my
money to the government the government
sucks but I love this they're going nuts
over this my god it's just unbelievable
okay this was the giantest fail the
giantest media fail since Geraldo Rivera
opened Al Capone's vault if you recall
where he made the big buildup no open Al
Capone's Al Capone's vault and then this
is what actually happened nearly two
hours ago we had no real idea what we'd
find inside as it turns out we haven't
found very much at least not yet in any
case I think that a legend a
half-century older so has been resolved
I don't know if we've gone far enough
and we found the other wall over there
there may be moments in TV history and
Rachel Maddow topped it because at least
it was Geraldo doing something
ridiculous about Al Capone's vault from
like 50 60 years before Rachel Maddow is
doing something about the most
sought-after document in modern
presidential history Donald Trump's tax
returns and she comes up absolutely
empty even the left doesn't know exactly
why this is happening to them even the
left is looking at this going what in
the world like that know this Don Lemon
said how is this not good for Trump how
how is this not good for Donald Trump oh
I think it may be good for Donald Trump
I mean one of the things that's very
strange about this is Donald Trump
probably would benefit from releasing
his tax returns with a lot of data Kate
Johnson the guy who's speaking right
there David Kate Johnson is the guy who
apparently anonymously received the
actually turns in his in his mail now do
I believe that Trump leaks his own tax
returns no I don't believe Trump leaks
his own tax returns because if he wanted
to do that he could have done that a
long time ago wouldn't have hurt him at
all for him to do it like why would he
do it now it doesn't saying that he was
trying to distract from the Trump care
fail but I don't I don't buy that but it
wouldn't surprise me if some guy named
John Miller had done it right for those
who know John Miller is actually a
trumpian alter-ego he uses PR guy again
the only reason I say that is because
it's really funny like they they go
through this whole rigmarole about the
tax returns now does this answer every
question people have about the tax
returns of course not because the fact
is that we still don't have Trump's tax
returns from any time in the last ten
years we still don't know why exactly we
won't release them and it seems to me
that the same logic that people had with
regard to Obama's birth certificate
should certainly apply to Trump right
all the people who said that Obama was
actually born in Kenya the reason he's
not revealing his birth certificate is
because he's actually born in Kenya and
then turned that Obama reveals his birth
certificate and he's of course not born
in Kenya those same people they're not
calling for Trump's tax returns but you
would imagine that by the same logic
they should be saying there's something
nefarious in there the Trump doesn't
want you to see now it's very possible
that Trump is just trolling people the
same way Obama did Obama trolled people
for years on his birth certificate it's
possible the Trump is trolling people
for years on his tax returns and
eventually he releases them and there's
nothing in them it's also possible that
it shows that he's not worth 10 billion
dollars he's worth like two billion
dollars and Trump is such an egomaniac
that it's quite possible that he thinks
that this would somehow sink him in the
public estimation like we're all out
here sitting around going well you know
now we know he's a liar he's only worth
two billion dollars guess he ain't dat
rich hmm again that's that's really
silly if that's why he's doing it but
you know we still haven't answered why
he hasn't released the tax returns but
it just demonstrated the media's desire
for a silver bullet for Trump is so high
this is why people were sitting on this
last night this is why for the first
time anyone watched Rachel Maddow
scrappy show was because they were
hoping they'd tune in and suddenly she'd
reveal hundreds of pages of tax returns
and some were buried deep in there would
be Donald Trump trying to take a
deduction for child sex slavery or
something there'd be a silver bullet
buried somewhere in there to destroy
Donald Trump didn't happen just
hilarious Trump himself released a
statement last night you can always tell
when
himself releases the statements because
the statements are included or totally
if a statement includes the word totally
then Donald Trump wrote it so here is
what the statement said before being
elected president mr. Trump was one of
the most successful businessmen in the
world with a responsibility to his
company his family and his employees to
pay no more tax than legally required
that being said mr. Trump paid 38
million dollars even after taking into
account large scales depreciation for
construction on an income of more than
150 million dollars as well as paying
tens of millions of dollars in other
taxes such as sales and excise taxes and
employment taxes and this illegally
published return just proves that you
can also tell it's a Trump taxi at a
Trump statement because of the run-on
sentences despite the substantial income
figure and tax paid it is totally
illegal to steal and publish tax returns
the dishonest media can continue to make
this part of their agenda while the
president will focus on his which
includes tax reform that will benefit
all Americans good for Trump I don't see
anything wrong with from statement it is
not illegal by the way for Rachel Maddow
to put this on the air so long as she
didn't actually steal the documents or
illegally obtained the documents if
somebody just handed them to her like an
informant he handed them to her and she
went with them then she didn't do
anything particularly illegal again
Trump could not have planned this better
if she if she didn't if she if Trump it
didn't have anything to do with this
he should have because it's just
incredible she humiliated herself on
national television in a major way
demonstrating once and for all that all
the media want from all of this is just
to destroy Trump well pause it for a
second and say thank you to our friends
over at the United States
concealed-carry Association so if you're
somebody who needs firearms education or
training or self-defense insurance you
know you got into a shooting incident
and you need somebody to help you with
the defense somebody breaks in your
house you shoot them doesn't mean the
police won't arrest you or you won't be
prosecuted that's why you need to talk
to my friends over at the u.s. CCA but
they have something particularly cool
right now and that is if you go to
defend my family now.com defend my
family now calm you can enter to win the
chance to win $1,500 for any gun you
want ten of my listeners are going to
get $1,500 for any gun that they want by
going to defend my family now calm there
are no restrictions any gun any brand
any caliber you want you enter to win
fifteen hundred bucks for the gun of
your dreams quick simply free defend my
family now calm Plus you should go there
anyway not just for the chance to win
the money but defend my family now calm
you go
there right now and and get all the
information that you could possibly want
or need about concealed carry about gun
ownership about where you can find
training about where you can find legal
help they're a great organization I
couldn't speak more highly of them
United States concealed carry
Association defend my family now.com
again is the place to go to get all
their information as well as to enter
for your chance ten my listener is gonna
win 1,500 bucks for any gun they want us
EC a fantastic organization defend my
family now dot-com
it's a sean hannity last night kind of
assuming that this was going to be a big
disaster for trump he went out there and
he did his show and he said that NBC was
waging a corporate jihad against trump
they are breaking laws all in an effort
to undermine and d legitimize the newly
elected president NBC News in particular
is on a political jihad against the
president and his administration ok now
I can say that that Rachel Maddow is
awful at her job I can say that MSNBC
obviously has a political bias and that
most of journalism is now perpetuated
against Donald Trump that's true then he
says NBC's waging a corporate jihad
against Trump I don't like words like
jihad because the idea that it's like
some sort of holy war equivalent to you
know the people who are actually
murdering people all over the world I
think is really silly and I think it's
over-the-top but you can see why the
right thinks this about the left you can
see why the right looks at what happened
on matter last night and we say guys you
are out of your damn minds if you think
that this is how you're gonna bring down
the president you must be totally crazy
I thought the most ironic thing though
was last night there was a Hillary
spokesman and Brian Fallon and if you
recall Hillary Clinton said the Donald
Trump paid nothing in taxes during the
campaign should the reason he won't
reveal his tax returns is because he
paid nothing in taxes this is Hillary
during the campaign why won't he release
his tax returns and I think there may be
a couple of reasons first maybe he's not
as rich as he says he is second maybe
he's not as charitable as he claims to
be
third we don't know all of his business
dealings but we have been told through
investigative reporting that he owes
about six hundred and fifty million
dollars to Wall Street and foreign banks
or maybe
he doesn't want the American people all
of you watching tonight
to know that he's paid nothing in
federal taxes because the only years
because because obviously that's not
true now her spokesman comes forward and
says pay no attention to those tax
returns showing that he actually paid 38
million dollars in taxes we shouldn't
step return focus to Trump care tomorrow
and the millions it will leave on in
shirts oops oops we stepped on the rake
and hit us in the face and now we should
switch the topic because that did not go
quite as planned
oopsies so is it okay to enjoy the short
and Freud of the of the entire left
stepping on its own feet with regard to
Trump's tax returns on this one yeah it
is should Trump still release his tax
returns yeah he should but for the
moment let's just enjoy the spectacle of
Rachel Maddow making a huge deal out of
the fact that Donald Trump is very rich
and pays lots of taxes because it's
quite spectacular we're gonna talk a
little bit more about Trump care and the
confusion therein we're also going to be
talking about what is easily the
greatest prank in history played by
4chan this is a fantastic fantastic
prank you're gonna want to hear about
but to hear about that to see that you
got to subscribe over at daily wire comm
8 bucks a month we'll get you a
subscription to Taylor wire and and
today do we have a special deal from the
annual subscribers yet Jonathan I don't
know if it's up yet or not so so annual
subscribers you know what I'm just gonna
say it is and then people will be on the
hook so that's just the way it works so
okay so the the annual subscribers today
we have a new deal for you annual
subscribers the number one Amazon
best-selling book a masterwork of
thoroughness a comprehensive
investigation into leftist ideology our
own Michael J Knowles BA Yale University
his book his number one best-selling
book reasons to vote Democrat yes it's
260 pages of blank paper and yes it does
have a quote from me on the front that
says Thoreau you can get that for free
right now when you're an annual
subscribe to get it signed by our own
Michael channels and he is just eager to
sign them for you in fact as I showed
you the other day he signs copies to
himself he inscribes copies of his own
book to himself because that's who
Michael J Knowles is but you can get a
copy of that for free a signed copy for
free when you become an annual
subscriber at daily wire.com
and you're gonna want to anyway cuz that
way you can see the rest of the show
live you can see klevens show live you
can become part of the mail
we're gonna have a Shapiro store that
starts very shortly we have a couple of
books that I'm gonna release in the next
few months that are gonna be great
you're gonna want to be able to get
discounts on and get a piece of so go
over to Daley wired.com right now and
subscribe otherwise just wait until
later and listen to iTunes or SoundCloud
and leave us a rating on iTunes if
you're a fan if you're not a fan then
don't leave a rating instead just listen
and then turn off your phone but in any
case we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you